hey guys Pete here today I'm going to be
breaking down the west-world season 3
episode 3 trailer which to be honest
doesn't show a lot but we can connect it
to some of the other preseason trailers
that are out there for a substantial
look at what's to come so we'll call it
a trailer breakdown slash preview for
episode 3 and Before we jump into it
this video will contain spoilers and
speculation about the upcoming season of
Westworld so if you don't want to know
about things that are out there in the
media and trailers this video will not
be for you episode 2 focused primarily
on mave waking up in the real world with
CEREC and bernard bringing Stubbs back
from Westworld we didn't get any Dolores
or Caleb so it makes sense that we'd
pick up right where we left off with
them this trailer opens in an ambulance
we see Dolores laying there with a mask
we hear her say the way they built their
world it won't take much to bring it all
crashing down there's only a couple of
shots to work with here Dolores was
incapacitated when we last saw her and
it makes sense that she would end up in
an ambulance it also makes sense that
she wouldn't want to be taken to the
hospital since she's not human and they
would probably figure that out fairly
quickly so we see her grab a scalpel and
overtake the EMT who had the misfortune
of responding to this call after that we
see her walking with Caleb on a pier and
the voice over Caleb says what are you
going to do to witch Dolores answers
start a revolution as mentioned there's
not much to go on but we have glimpse
more of these scenes in previous
trailers the one Caleb meets Dolores
trailer fills in the blanks for what
will happen after the ambulance scene so
it's worth the closer look it does in
fact show though ambulance from the
outside and it shows that Caleb is in
there with her that's where the idea
that she's being transported right after
they came together in the last episode
comes from on the pier they're wearing
different clothes she's cleaned-up and
looks recovered from her injuries in the
Caleb meets Dolores trailer we see them
in the same clothes doing their
introductions and
getting breakfast together Dolores
orders for Caleb which surprises him and
hints that she knows things about him
even though they've just met this is the
overall gist of that trailer they meet
they get to know each other and then
they work together
she says she's had her eye on him and
that she thinks he's the one she's been
waiting for for us as viewers the
question is why what is it about Caleb
that she's interested in after all he's
just sort of a regular guy he doesn't
seem to have any big connection to
insight or anything like that based on
what we've seen so far my guess is that
it has something to do with him
mentioning in episode 1 that he
deactivated his implant this idea comes
from one of their calls in that Francis
asked Caleb if he'd consider getting his
implant turned back on
he says the implant helped smooth over
the rough edges some people need it but
for me I guess the rough edges are the
only thing I'm hanging on to I'm
interpreting that the implant is related
to how data is collected by insight but
even if it's not him turning off the
implant and deciding to stop the work
with the AI version of Francis shows
he's trying to rebel against the
algorithm in some sense however that
plays out something he's doing makes him
unique and that makes Delores want him
it could also be that he has this
military background and things like that
but I feel like him mentioning the
implant was important the second half of
the episode 3 trailer is about Hale
which I talked about a lot in my last
breakdown of the in the weeks ahead
trailer there are some added bits here
and a reveal that I was correct in
thinking that the boy was Charlotte's
child the voice-over we hear is Delores
telling Hale remember who you are now
let me show you who you need to pretend
to be this is probably a flashback since
it's at Arnold's home
we know the Loras was moving around
before ending up in Los Angeles where
she currently is as we see here
whoever's inside the host Charlotte body
has moved on to San Francisco where
she's taking the real Charlotte's place
that involves taking over her duties of
running things at Delos after most of
the board members were killed in taking
care of her child we know at San
Francisco
because that's where Delos headquarters
is located we're all wondering which
host consciousness is in there
and they're wondering why they have to
be there in the first place
we know that Dolores was able to
impersonate Charlotte in the park now
she's able to pass that information on
to whichever characters inside there and
it makes sense that it might be an
uncomfortable transformation we hear
them say they feel like they're changing
which is an interesting road they could
go down
they also say why do I have to be her
which may mean that there's some
connection the person knows hail I'm not
a hundred percent sure about that are
there any other hints of who it could be
not really in looking back at season two
once you know Dolores is inside the hell
hosts you can see that Tessa Thompson
does a great job in her portrayal she
copies things that Evan Rachel Wood does
at the time you really couldn't that
much though because there was all this
timeline confusion that was going on at
the same time we get quite a few looks
at this happening here based on her
expressions but nothing that gives away
the game in my mind Teddy is off the
table since he was uploaded to the
sublime and Dolores does say in this
trailer that she trusts the hosts that
she put in there that makes me lean
towards it being her father in the park
Peter Abernathy but it's not exactly
clear if his personality could be
recovered after the events of season two
or if he would have any feelings about
being in Charlotte Hales body same goes
for Clementine as far as that can the
personality be restored and then it's
not exactly clear why Dolores would say
that she trusts her the other candidate
is Angela which we saw blow herself up
in the cradle so there's problems with
her as well and it's really up in the
air of course there's always a chance
that it's a hybrid it's someone that
Dolores created there's a popular theory
that there's multiple copies of Dolores
--is control unit so that she's in both
I don't think anything in this trailer
makes me lean one way or the other the
takeaway is that is that whoever's in
there has a crucial role to play going
forward and it may be a difficult
transition where they don't exactly take
to this role I don't expect that we're
gonna find out right away but I'm
guessing we'll get more clues with each
new episode beyond that we don't see any
Bernard Stubbs may or Sarah
this teaser we did see a conversation
between Maeve and Ciroc in the weeks
ahead trailer so hopefully they will
appear the same goes for man in black we
haven't seen him at all yet in season 3
and he's in several of the trailers that
are out there so I guess it's just a
matter of time although it may not be in
this episode I'm thinking we'll focus
mostly on Dolores and Caleb and we may
also see them attend this party where it
looks like they approach Liam jr. again
since the Loras went out of her way to
replace Martin Connells was a host we
can expect that Liam is still part of
her plan and we know Bernard is looking
for him because he saw her in his
memories and that's probably where these
stories will come back together I got
the feeling in Episode two that Bernard
and Maeve think they know what Dolores
is up to but it's likely that it's gonna
turn out that they're wrong Bernard is
thinking she wants to destroy mankind
but based on what we've seen or do and
things that we've heard to tell other
characters that doesn't appear to be
what her endgame is as I said in other
videos I think it's most likely that
they're all going to end up working
together but now that may biz with CEREC
we'll have to see how that changes
things we'll definitely get a better
idea after this episode the other things
that we see in when Kaleb met Dolores
trailer are a lot of action sequences
not sure if those are going to come up
in this episode and then we also see
them hook up with the characters that
are played by Lena weaith and Marshawn
Lynch so those two may be making a
return in this episode as well and
that's pretty much it so let me know in
the comments what you think what you're
looking forward to how do you feel about
the season so far
I've enjoyed both episodes they were
kind of like good bookends to setting
the table we'll see where things go from
here in episode 2 I appreciated how they
brought up some mysteries and they
wrapped up some things it was pretty
tight all the way around curious to see
what Zurich is all about and how
everything's gonna play in the coming
weeks please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon